Keller jacket break that up down the
right wing D forth looks to cut in
does a backhand attempt left in the blue
paint before Ingram himself sweeps it away
he decides early here he's going to take
this right to the net and almost tucks it
[Music] home Puck set ahead and on the left wing
machell looks cross ice the jackets are there to
break it up they cannot clear though now stetcher
in the slot shot from the wing a Scramble with B
leans down the puck drilled Elvis without his goal
stick he'll grab it Krauss cannot get a stick on
it in their own end it's a clear that goes wrong
early in this and then the kyot try kyot tried to
go to work you can see this mad scramble Elvis
is on his belly and as he gets up he makes a
remarkable save he gets back up on his feet as the
jackets move up and it's marchenko down the right
wing marchenko with a shot rebound a scramble in
front Ingram unable to control that rebound the
Jacket's got a second attempt that's why we're
not seeing a lot of chances in odd man rushes
you can see the the white coverage on the way back
not a lot of space but marenko does an excellent
knocked off the puck there and the Blue Jackets
counter and move up ice it's a two-on one moving
in there's a shot and a glove save by Ingram Blue
Jackets and they jump all over and it's Dan for's
effort there and an effort he just puts it in an
area for texier who loads up jackets March out of
Their Own Zone coming in with speed on the left
wing sharp angle shot save thrown back in front
Ingram looks behind him and the puck swept to the
wall take a look at some of the one of the chances
here as fentil he's going to throw this puck in
and then stay with it it's a quick play short side
that creates a lot of problems you see as Jenner
just gets the toll stick on it good row across
the line broken up and here's a rush shorthanded
could be a two onone moving in Elvis looks behind
them and covers up really skated into the defense
of the Arizona Coyotes and here they come up ice
it's a quick transition and then Elvis does a nice
job there keeping it and then staying above that
goal line around the boards marchenko will let
it go to the point he'll get handed the puck off
deals it back power play over the jackets fail
to get a shot ROV as the jackets keep the puck
in the offensive zone here's drill and scores
serson how many times in recent games have we
seen the jackets failed to score in the power play
and then come right back seconds later and here's
another one one- nothing serson wasting time with
that puck at all you can see that play in front
by baronov as that puck whistles through there
and then it's quickly back on the far side and
here's what you're seeing stepping into that
puck that Puck's moving perfectly for cson
and the Blue Jackets up one nothing Puck deep in
Columbus territory good Branson oh his pass picked
off Elvis with a big stop there off the Stick of
Hatton from Point Blank Range right away how about
this play right here as you mentioned Barrett
Hatton gets that shot gets down on one KNE haon
drops it there BS holding on looks cross ice shot
save M lein rebound juggle but held by the jackets
net minder it's that left left Pat out and it just
settles right into that and here is Elvis drops
that Puck and you see him try to get in there on
the texier looking to return the feed he'll get
the shot through as the Coyote's handed it right
back to Alexander texier now schaltz will deal to
the point wrist shot through a crowd again Elvis
is there despite the screen and just back handed
it off into the corner he hears from the crowd
another attempt left in front and [Applause]
scores the coyotes have come back to tie it
couple clearing attempts go wrong they're
stuck in their own end and it's going
to end up to be a broken play here as
this Puck's going to come off of Michael King
stick and there you can see that puck bounces
right across the other way and there's the shot
you see that deflection once and there's haon
he's had a couple chances in there as Bean
got him he gets up front that puck bounces
right to him and he's got that open net to M
lein will leave it there for serson who has
the lone Columbus G picked up thrown in front
oh what a great save from Point Blank Range by
Elvis M leans good row as brown steps up hugad
turns air great play quick shot van Tilly and
that one fought off by Ingram some movement
you want to see on the power play it's you
Zach it was a good hard P power play second for
the coyotes they had one shot in their previous
attempt [__] with a shot scores it's a power
play goal the coie shot I believe was tipped in
front and and it is on that power play
goal yeah you can see the defender in
tight and it's tight down low and it's a
simple power play as they work it up top
and you can see that deflection right in
front Elvis has got good sight lines but
it's that not sure if Provo tipped that
looked like it might have got touched
no is second of the season and the jacket string
of 23 straight eight kills over 10 games comes to
an end and now a quick goal there by Lawson
Krauss and the coyotes lead by two that's a
top line out there you can try to get out
there and get something going all this is
frustration as all of a sudden they're down by
two and Pascal Vincent here now has got to get
something going for this team to play in their
own end but here's again the the Arizona Coyotes
they stretch out the the neutral zone they get
out of their Zone quickly you can see no one
identifies that player in the high slot and look
at all the time behind the net for buad he's got
no one on him he's got plenty of time and late
arrival there for chikov they also have Power
Play Goals in seven straight moving in save Elvis
rebounds Swept Away coyote in the corner so ky's
goal from Jersey as the jackets come back
and Ingram with a big save with Jenner in
the front of the net WoW excellent play there
cylinder to Trey fix wanski hard P to Boone I
don't know if he just missed that or not he's
not happy moving in Travis boy denied by murin
up high coyotes Jersey dancing coyotes will
send it here to Moser Moser under to schaltz
to the right point back here for schaltz on the
left side right-handed shot and this one off the
crossbar where it beats the goal post wow Recs
got a claw back here until he dumps in deep he
leads all skaters with seven shots wraparound
attempt there by marchenko again the right
idea fresh faces on this is brown takes a hit
actually rolled off it from marenko goes back
by the jackets Winger texier deals the point
cross ice serson with the shot scores David
Severson who scored earlier has cut the deficit to
one and there's a minute 57 left a good pressure
by the Blue Jackets in the offensive zone and
on the quiet side it's Damon Severson gets into
the position he wants and he unloads it it's
a Nissan move of the game see the for check
of marenko you mentioned he's been working here
all night he understands the important of being
the first guy in the for check and he does that
and look what it opens up Damon Severson there's
no stick handling There's No Nonsense he's got
his head up he's got a Clear Sight line here
and that puck goes right past the blocker from
the drop sson walking the line quite a crowd in
front of Ingram shot by fantelli rebound Ingram
got a piece of it descended high off The netting
the jackets all around the Coyote's neck look
at this play right in front picked up by Dumba
final seconds jeder with it the game is over well
no good Dr No lining out there for the last two
shifts and Arizona hangs on and the desperation
level for the Blue Jackets gets extremely h